YUSUF DAHL: I believe
anything is possible.
Your past does not have
to dictate your future.
My name's Yusuf Dahl.
I am recently graduated
from the Woodrow Wilson
School of Public and
International Affairs
with my master's degree.
I grew up in
Milwaukee, Wisconsin,
in an environment of
really extreme adversity.
At 18 years old, I was sentenced
to the Wisconsin prison
system for 10 and 1/2
years for possession
of a controlled substance.
It was a moment
that I resolved
I was going to spend every
single moment that I had,
making sure that I
acquired the education that
would allow me to take control
and change the trajectory
of my own individual life.
When I was released, I
applied to hundreds of jobs.
My mother had saved a
pair of dress shoes I had,
that I wore to my
sentencing at 18 years old.
I literally wore the
soles out of those shoes,
going door-to-door
to businesses,
trying to find work.
My big break,
actually, came when
I was hired by the
state of Wisconsin.
At 28 years old, I received
my bachelor's degree
in information sciences.
And it was during my time
as a graduate student
that the foreclosure crisis hit.
And so as my neighbors began
to abandon their homes,
as blight began
to move in, I had
to make a decision
of what I would do.
I knew that I had a
responsibility to my community.
And without any formal training,
I began to buy foreclosed homes
and renovate them.
I helped lobby for
significant legislation
in the state of
Wisconsin, and was
honored with being present
at two bill signings
next to Governor Scott Walker.
I knew that I wanted to have
a bigger impact, one that was
national, rather than local.
And that's when I decided to
apply to Princeton University.
Princeton is just
a phenomenal place.
It's absolutely,
indelibly changed
how I look at the world,
and how I view my ability
to have an impact in it.
MARTIN JOHNSON: Yusuf brings
an unusual background,
for a lot of reasons.
He has this awesome
life experience
that he can bring to the
academic world, which
not many can do.
And if you're teaching
practical courses,
like a course on social
entrepreneurship,
this is the kind of guy
you want around you.
This is the kind of guy who can
offer both personal, as well
as the professional,
and do it in a way that
is lighthearted and thoughtful.
ANNOUNCER: Yusuf Dahl.
YUSUF DAHL: Coming
to Princeton was
the first time I was
in school full time
since I was 15 years old.
So the level of rigor that
was expected when I originally
got here was quite difficult.
After a very rough
first semester, I made some
changes, met some people who
were a lot smarter than I was,
built a team of resources,
and I was able to thrive over my
last year and a half on campus.
And through Princeton,
I've been able to spend
a summer in Africa.
I've been to Germany.
It's just been a
wonderful experience,
and I'm very thankful
for the resources
that they've provided
for me, to achieve
my own, individual potential.
I'm extremely proud to be an
alumnus of this university,
and I look forward to being
able to leverage the experiences
and resources that
I've gained on campus,
to having a bigger impact.
[MUSIC PLAYING]